foreign
there is out there
london-based Synthesia are a leader in
using machine intelligence to turn text
into video we make video production easy
for our clients I sat down with Daniel
only it's not him speaking including
one-third of the Fortune 100 but his
Avatar so all that had to happen is me
speaking into camera for two three
minutes and then we were able to train
our AEI models let's get started their
clients are businesses wanting to create
and revise realistic video presentations
in any language but they're Keen to
stress they're not creating deep fakes
there is much more under the hood of
these given that we only create
someone's likeness with their explicit
consent you can't just generate video of
anyone We Believe That explicit consent
content moderation and really working
with the wider Community are the keys to
an ethical platform
but the proliferation of other AIS
trained on any data you want in some
cases the entire internet threatens to
pollute the online world with a tidal
wave of misinformation harmful content
or just rubbish if you look at coding
fifty percent of all the code generated
now is AI generated can we set standards
around what we feed them so we don't
feed them junk food we feed them better
quality inputs so they have better
quality outputs small Stack's company
has just launched its latest text to
image AI deep Floyd if you can imagine
it it can make a picture of it raising
questions about copyright and Truth can
we get it to generate a bit of a fake
news story a UFO looming down over the
houses of Parliament in London
okay wow the problem is even using some
classic tools like Photoshop people can
do a lot of fakes nowadays I think maybe
in the next few years we will see a lot
of fake images that will be very very
close to real quality clearly these
images are watermarked to show their AI
generated but it doesn't take much
expertise to get around that and no one
quite knows how to spot AI generated
text this happened with social media you
know maybe a decade ago is that the
technology moves so fast and the Bad
actors can explode it quicker than uh
protections can be put in place we
remain really concerned about
uh just an average internet user's
ability to find accurate information and
know that that is the accurate
information
whether their products are
self-contained business tools or
publicly available content generating
machines AI Pioneers say regulation is
needed but while we wait to see what
that looks like the technology races
ever onwards Tom Clark Sky News